tiens manuel doman bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors là
relations de l'union européenne avec la
russie au menu donc un les discussions
des 27 aujourd'hui pour josep borrell
chef de la diplomatie de l'ue eux et
bien ses relations seraient au plus bas
est ce que c'est vraiment le cas
aujourd'hui
oui c'est la réalité géopolitique
parce que depuis 2014 avec la question
ukrainienne et la crise en ukraine
l'union européenne et la russie sont
entrés dans une spirale de sanctions
réciproque et le nioro peine en réalité
refuse la réalité géopolitique delà du
retour de la russie comme une puissance
qui compte non seulement en europe mais
aussi dans le monde et dans le contexte
général la configuration internationale
l'union européenne en réalité refuse le
monde multipolaire se considère comme un
sous-ensemble de l'espace euro
atlantique avec une alliance privilégiée
que les états unis complémentaire de
l'otan alors que la russie fait la
promotion d'un monde multipolaire
multi-centres et avec un meilleur
équilibre et une europe des nations donc
il y a un compte pas incompatibilité des
vision géopolitique européenne
alors la semaine dernière josep borrell
à employer à un triptyque a riposté
contraindre dialoguer est ce que les
vingt-sept sont unis quant à la
stratégie affichée de l'europe face à la
russie non ils ne sont pas unis
l'administration de l'union européenne
elle-même son service extérieur est très
atlantiste
donc il il considère que l'union
européenne est complémentaire de l'otan
est en réalité il il accepterait une
relation constructive avec la russie
mais à la condition que la russie
s'aligne sur les priorités de l'union
européenne et ses principes idiot le
hic la société où est la démocratie
libérale ça c'est la position de l'union
européenne est qui et qui travaillent en
synergie avec le temps et ne fait pas
d'initiatives sans l'approbation sans le
contexte des de la posture américaine
mais les états membres eux mêmes ont des
positions différentes et ils ont du mal
à avoir une position commune forte parce
que vous avez les pays bell par pays
bâle par exemple et pologne qui sont
très méfiants de la russie la france
avec sa tradition de puissance d'
équilibre qui aimerait bien une une
meilleure relation que la russie
notamment pour contrebalancer
l'allemagne au niveau européen mais
aussi les états unis et la chine tandis
que l'allemagne a aimerait une garder
une relation économique très forte en
tant que puissance centrale économique
dans l'union européenne notamment avec
l'accès à l'énergie mais considère que
c'est l'otan qui qui est le lac ce
central pour sa sécurité et souhaitent
contrebalancer la russie pour garder son
leadership en europe sans d'europe
centrale et orientale
alors nos qu'il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de
convergence franco-allemande eux malgré
certains les déclarations récentes
d'ailleurs qui ce qui se réalise alors
même que les états unis ont commencé à
négocier avec les etats-unis les
européens attendent toujours un petit
peu l'approbation le les avancées
américaines au lieu d'anticiper alors
justement alors elles n'ont pas été
validés mais c'est dans les conclusions
de ce sommet le couple franco allemand
qui souhaite aujourd'hui plus de
dialogue avec la russie est ce que la
rencontre la semaine dernière entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden a eu un
impact sur la posture européenne oui
bien sûr parce que les européens s'ils
sont divisés et maintiennent une
relation difficile que la russie d'un
autre côté les etats-unis avancent ce
commence à négocia clé russie sur des ce
dossier stratégique qui courent
les européens aussi par exemple sur les
questions de désarmement avec le traité
start et si les européens ne se non pas
une posture commune vis-à-vis la russie
n'essaye pas aussi de d'engager un
dialogue plus profond et bien les
etats-unis la russie vont négocier par
dessus la tête des européens donc
évidemment ce serait dans l'intérêt
géopolitique des états européens la
question demeure quelle position commune
peuvent-ils à aborder à cause de cette
rivalité franco allemand pour le pouvoir
aussi dans l'union européenne où ils
n'ont pas exactement les mêmes objectifs
mais le temps presse et je pense que le
avec la proposition notamment de
vladimir poutine
dans sa lettre dans le journal die zeit
en allemagne de renouer avec la vision
d'une europe de lisbonne à vladivostok
de l'atlantique au pacifique que le
général de gaulle avait déjà anticipé
il serait temps évidemment de répondre à
cette à ses visions mais il ya toujours
cet aspect idéologique que l'union
européenne et les états européens nom
sur la promotion de multilatéralisme et
non pas de la multipolarité c'est-à-dire
d'imposer leur leurs règles leurs
priorités et ne considère pas la russie
comme un partenaire égal c'est ça la
difficulté
merci beaucoup pierre emmanuel thomann
pour votre éclairage ce matin dans la
matinale je vous rappelle vous êtes
professeur en géopolitique et fondateur
d'euro continent